We've been cleaning out the lab so that it can be refurbished so we can teach
our students better and hidden. At the back,
we found a really long tube.
Which P license.
That had made to do the barking dog experiment, our favorite experiments,
but he'd found that it was a bit awkward to use in lectures.
So it'd been forgotten.
Bulking dogs are usually done in quite a short too. [inaudible]
it's over a meter long, and this one is seriously long,
probably three or four meters long.
So you probably will remember it because you've seen it lots of times in our
videos.
It's the reaction of carbon disulfide with [inaudible] nitrous oxide.
And we've got our barking dog ready to go. Let's see if it box.
So you fill it too with nitrous, oxide, gas,
add some water, then you pour in a cup and they sell five.
That's a liquid.
And then you shake the tube and the water mixes everything up.
And it could mix. So you can ensure that we get all of that calmness off.
I going into the vapor phase two to react really quite quickly without oxygen
and two.
So the water as you turn the tube sloshes up and down,
and that's rather like a piston to help mix the carbon de
sulfide, which is evaporating with the end too.
So you get the gas phase mixture.
And of course the more you shake it all being well, the better it's mixed.
[Inaudible]. So with the first one.
We tried,
what happened was that we were in a bit of a hurry and I don't think
perhaps we mixed it well enough,
because what happened was that when the tube was lit,
the first 30 centimeters or so lit up,
and the flame was almost stationary,
Neil had time to walk away from the experiment
and then slowly the flame started accelerating down the
tube and then surprisingly in the middle, it almost stopped.
Might've even gone up a bit.
And then it went with a nice flush down to the bottom and it gave a very
nice deep note,
which those of you who study physics were realized the longer tube you have
as in an organ tube, the deeper the note. So that wasn't surprising.
[Inaudible].
But what I thought was that perhaps some of the,
um, effect that we'd seen was because of the bad mixing.
So in some places we had almost too much carbon sulfide,
it was rich in fuel and other places.
There was a lot of nitrous oxide, and not much those self-aid,
which explained the sort of stop start of the whole thing.
The other thing which you might see in the particularly the slow motion pictures
is that the reaction gives us quite a lot of ultraviolet light,
which makes Neil's white lab coat fluoresce.
It suddenly looks purple and quite impressively.
So I persuaded Neil to clean the tube and
try and experiment the next day. Now,
the reason why it took some persuading is because when the sulfur is
formed on the walls, it's initially formed in a form of sulfur.
That's called plastic sulfur,
which is made up of long chains of self rattans,
which are insoluble and most common solvents.
So you can't just wash it out. However,
if you wait a few days,
then the plastic selfer turns into so-called
Rumbek sulfur, which contains S eight rings,
which is dissolved and all sorts of common solvent.
So you've just put in this liquid and you can wash it out in a few minutes.
So normally we just wait and then it's easy to clean.
But this time Neil was really scrubbing hard.
The next day we tried again, he mixed for a long time,
and this time the reaction went much better.
It still began with quite a slow start,
but then it went more smoothly with some bouncing,
like we've seen before,
possibly the bouncing again, due to the shockwave, hitting the bottom.
And we got some very nice fluorescence from Neil's lab coat.
[Inaudible].
If you look at the tube, the Selfridge is still not deposited uniformly.
So I think we got the mixing good enough to get good demonstration.
We didn't get the mixing good enough to get to completely uniform reacts.
And I think this illustrates a very important point about chemical
reactions.
That can be very important for the results and the bigger the
vessel you have. The more important it is to get your mixing uniform,
or you can get some free, strange results.
The second thing was that we noticed something that we'd seen before the flame
shoots along the tube,
and then suddenly stops and bounces and goes rather more slowly, but also late.